el mandato de lenin moreno es un buen
ejemplo el próximo presidente de ecuador
no lo va a tener fácil en primer lugar
tendrá que lidiar con una sociedad
polarizada y un debate público centrado
en dos palabras constantes correa y
venezuela hugo por un andrew zarautz
candidato apadrinado por el ex
presidente ecuatoriano genera esperanzas
en sectores de la población que rechazan
la austeridad y reivindican un mayor
papel social del estado
del otro lado detractores de rafael
correa consideran que volver al
socialismo llevaría al país a
convertirse en venezuela
este debate no se puede entender sin la
maltrecha economía ecuatoriana desde
2015 el país vive la desaceleración
económica por la caída de los precios
del petróleo una dependencia a la que se
le suma a una pandemia que deja 600.000
desempleados una economía contraída
entre un 10 y un 12 por ciento una deuda
que equivale al 60 por ciento del
producto interior bruto y una tasa de
pobreza en torno al 35 por ciento en
nuevo presidente además se encontrará
con una reestructuración del pago de la
deuda de 17
millones de dólares sin embargo tendrá
que decidir si acepta las contundentes
exigencias de austeridad del fondo
monetario internacional o si decide
enfrentarlas pero en lo que sigue
coinciden todos es en la necesidad de
empezar una campaña de vacunación que
vuelva a poner en marcha la economía en
un sistema de salud precario que se vio
superado en la primera ola de kobe 19 en
guayaquil segunda ciudad de ecuador el
nuevo presidente también tendrá que
lidiar con un organizado movimiento
indígena en 2019 ya demostró a lenin
moreno su capacidad para paralizar el
país por último la elección será clave
en un plano internacional
una victoria de arauz acercaría a
ecuador a bolivia argentina y podría
reactivar unasur mientras que también
por otro lado podría debilitar la
recuperada relación con eeuu